قبل أن أبدأ ، لدي بعض الأخبار المرحب بها
بأن
الحكومة السعودية قد أفرجت عن
الناشطة البارزة في مجال حقوق الإنسان
لوجين ألوثي لو لويل ،
عفواً لول من السجن
، لقد كانت مدافعة قوية عن
حقوق المرأة وكان إطلاق سراحها هو
الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب القيام
به لقد كان يومًا مزدحمًا  لقد أعلنت سابقًا عن
الخطوات التي اتخذناها لفرض
تكلفة على المسؤولين عن
الانقلاب العسكري في
بورما ، وقد انتهيت للتو من إحاطة إعلامية مع
القيادة العسكرية المدنية حيث
وضعت أولوياتي للأمن القومي
وأريد مشاركة الرسالة مباشرة مع
موظفو وزارة الدفاع في
جميع أنحاء العالم
لأن كل واحد منكم سواء
تم تجنيده حديثًا
ضابطًا مهنيًا أو ضابطًا غير مفوض
أو خبيرًا في السياسة المدنية ،
فأنت ضروري لكيفية إظهار
قوتنا في جميع أنحاء العالم